hey guys it's Justine and we were here
at WDC and right now we're checking out
an emoji and I'm super excited about
this when they announced this at the
event I was I was so excited because
this is something that I've been waiting
for so right now we're gonna go through
and we're gonna create it and first
we're gonna choose my skin we'll go for
the skin color you can choose from all
of these various colors there's so many
different options that you can choose
from it's pretty overwhelming you can
choose from freckles and as you can see
this is face tracking me the entire time
let's click for a hairstyle here's the
problem I have blonde hair my eyebrows
are not the same color it's of course
it's all natural Jenna obviously so
today I have curly hair so we're gonna
try to find a nice curly hair style
color but look how many hairstyle
options that there are like this is
overwhelming oh oh this Mohawk actually
looks good I got something I might want
to consider for my future okay that's a
little too curly I don't really wear
ponytails I like that that's a nice wave
could you see that like my hair is
bouncing not like an old real life in an
emoji life okay so we've got my
hairstyle I think it's a pretty accurate
color I came to get highlights that's
good oh oh no that's age so here look
how young I look young and vibrant I'm
gonna pick the middle one about this
these space shapes
okay looks like me great my eyes I'm not
sure what color my eyes are color they
green okay cool I think so too
okay let's see what is bit - my eyes
look like I think that looks like me oh
oh yeah Oh had some lashes oh this looks
great
okay that's me now I can pick my brows
oh my gosh this is so cool my gosh nose
and lips that's a nose it looks good
lips a little pink should I like purple
that looks good there's different lip
sizes too
okay those lips are way too big I need
you to turn down there's now tongue
detection so oh my goodness this is
incredible eight years I'm trying to
move my hair and I was thinking that it
was gonna work in the app but not yet
wow there's all kinds of piercings okay
that looks good we're gonna do that with
a nice rose gold because hello facial
hair no today but there are all these
options look how many there are
[Music]
it's like overwhelming look at my beard
we'll go to you okay
not saying you pick sunglasses you can
pick all these various glasses I
actually lost my glasses so I haven't
worn them for a very long time you can
also get lenses so you can make them be
just regular clear glasses or tinted
it's gonna put hats on look at your
different colored hats I'm gonna wear a
pink hat it's an option but I'm not
gonna do it okay so I'm gonna hit done
and there I am
okay okay no wonder I'm gonna record a
little message hey this is my first MIMO
G what do you guys think how do I look
I think it looks pretty good okay bye
just kidding cuz I have 30 seconds now
so I can keep going
this is great okay so in the camera icon
in the messages app there's this little
star right here so when you click that
that will bring up this whole little
area here so you can choose from your
meme oh geez oh my gosh this is so cool
okay I see a picture so let's pick it
there we go
so I can also pick a filter so let's do
the comic book one because that is very
very nice okay I'm also gonna throw a
sticker in here as well how about all an
ice cream cone now picture incredible oh
my goodness I am sending this to some
random account on this phone so I hope
that they enjoy my content because it's
pretty great well guys I think that is
it from emoji I'm super excited for this
there's been so many fun announcements
and of course as always I will be
posting more videos so stay tuned I'll
see you guys later
hey it's iJustine I'm AM emoji I'm
having so much fun this is so cool man
tongue detection it's a thing
[Music]